- [Interviewer] All right, Lauren.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Lauren,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- San Diego, California.
- [Interviewer] San Diego.
And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Until I was about 12.
- [Interviewer] And what happened at 12?
- My dad had 17 years in the Navy.
My mom said, I'm divorcing
you and taking half.
And Dad said, what's half of nothing?
- [Interviewer] And you went where?
- I stayed with my mom for awhile.
She was very authoritarian
and a little bit abusive.
So, went to Nebraska.
Hitchhiked to Nebraska, I was about 14.
- [Interviewer] So you ran
away at a very young age.
- Yeah.
And when I came back,
by the time I was 15 I
was out of the house,
living with my grandmother.
- [Interviewer] Living
with your grandmother?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Which was basically doing whatever.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, did
you finish high school?
- No, I dropped out in the 10th grade.
- [Interviewer] 10th grade?
No sexual abuse when you were a kid?
- No, you know what,
when I was about seven the neighbor boy,
that was, yeah, my
first sexual experience.
He had older brothers, I guess
that's where he got educated.
But I don't, you know,
two seven year olds,
I don't know if you'd consider
that necessarily abuse.
I was pretty naive at the time.
- [Interviewer] But you've
always been gay, you think?
- More, closer to bi.
- [Interviewer] Bi?
- Bi or pan.
If it pans out, you know.
- [Interviewer] So what have
you done with your life since
you, since you left town?
Left your grandmother.
- Not much, hustled and worked carnivals.
Started a family and
that just died miserably.
- [Interviewer] So you're a Carnie?
- Yeah, I'm a show person, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay. And
you have family as well?
- I have a son, yeah.
- [Interviewer] You have a son?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you were married once?
- [Interviewer] But
you're transgender now?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And when
did that start to emerge?
- Nine, seven, eight, maybe nine.
- [Interviewer] So you've known
this for a long, long time?
- Yeah, I just recently,
just got a little bit open about it.
- [Interviewer] Was it difficult
for you to not be open about it,
for all those years?
- Yeah, You know,
like when my parents split
up I was always fighting.
I realize it now, I was
fighting for acceptance.
This isn't what people did.
- [Interviewer] You think you
and your parents, kind of,
saw some of this in you?
- I don't think so.
- [Interviewer] No.
- You know, when I got out
on my own, it was, you know,
binge and purge, binge and purge.
Obviously I must have liked it,
cause I kept coming back to it.
When I got married, you know, very seldom,
but yeah, even then.
When I went back to work in the carnival
it was just not necessarily, you know...
usually too busy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, so tell
me about working in carnivals.
What is that like?
What'd you do for the carnival?
- I watched games, concessions.
- [Interviewer] So the little...
- You know, rubber
duckies, throwing darts,
popping balloons.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, how
many years have you done that?
- About 20 plus.
- [Interviewer] You travel all
over the country doing that?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
Matter of fact, I
stopped here to get my ID
three weeks before COVID,
when I was heading out to New York.
- [Interviewer] Three weeks before what?
- COVID started.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see.
So COVID kind of put a stop
to the carnival season?
- Yeah, and I figured while I was here,
might as well just hang
out for a little bit.
- [Interviewer] So
you're, you're fairly new
to San Francisco.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How are
you liking San Francisco?
- Overall, It's okay.
I came through in the late eighties.
I was here for a couple hours, you know,
over on Haight and Ashbury,
on the way to go see a dead show.
And it's not the same place I remember.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but
being, being trans here,
it probably is, it's more accepted than...
- Yeah. That has definitely
been a plus to it.
Probably why I decided
to hang out for so long.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And you, you have a son, you said?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How old's your son?
- Almost 30, 27.
- [Interviewer] And he's,
tell me about your son.
- We just basically reunited after about
17 years, 18 years.
When me and his mom split,
grandma didn't like me
and yeah, maybe it was just real bitter.
So I went back to work on the carnival.
I, I haven't even been back
to San Diego in 20 plus years.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see,
but do you talk to your son?
- Yeah, Facebook.
- [Interviewer] How's your
relationship with him?
- He's got problems.
And he's a grown man,
he can do what he wants.
It's just hard to watch some
of the decisions he's making.
- [Interviewer] Is it drugs?
- Yeah, yeah, heroin.
- [Interviewer] Heroin.
- Opiates.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And are drugs a part of your life as well?
- I smoke weed.
You know, long hours in the carnival,
but weed is how carnival
people sleep, in November.
So yeah, stimulants.
- [Interviewer] Like, like speed?
- Speed, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you been using speed
or crystal meth?
- Since I was 14.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah, I started young.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I
think the carny crowd...
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Takes to
that drug, don't they?
- Yeah, that crack, basically anything.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- My thing around it was
always to do what you do,
just handle what you do.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
and do you have friends?
- A few, yeah.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- Make some, you know, while
I'm here in San Francisco.
I got a lot of friends on
the road that, you know,
they're scattered across the country.
- [Interviewer] Right.
What's the most important
lesson you've learned,
in your years of doing all this?
- To thine own self be true.
- [Interviewer] You're doing that?
- Yeah.
If it doesn't feel right,
don't do it, you know?
At the end of the day, you know,
you still gotta look at yourself.
You still gotta live with yourself.
- [Interviewer] Are you,
do you think you're happier
this way than you were?
- It's, it...
I don't know if necessarily
happier would be the word for it.
It's definitely liberating and,
I feel free and more alive
than I have in years.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been trans for how long?
- I'd say it started when
I was just about nine.
- [Interviewer] You started
dressing as a woman?
- Yeah, yeah, you know, here and there.
Since I've been here I've pretty
much devoted myself to it.
- [Interviewer] Becoming
more open about it?
- Yeah, yeah.
Contemplating, you know,
where it's going, you know,
where it's going to go
in my life at the moment.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, do you
feel like you've been loved
in your life by your parents or?
- My grandmother.
- [Interviewer] Your grandmother?
- My grandmother, yeah.
I miss her.
- [Interviewer] You were born
this way, you believe, right?
- Yes, yeah.
It wasn't a choice.
Matter of fact, I've tried
making conscious choices
not to be.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
'cause a lot of society sees
it as wrong, right?
- Right, right.
From the religious down to, you know,
Joe Schmoe on the street.
The homeless aren't
really accepting of it.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
you get, like, treated badly,
because you're trans on the street?
- Being in the carnival industry,
the outdoor amusement industry,
it's no worse than that.
You know, you pull into a town
you're instantly hated, so.
They either love you or they hate you, so.
I mean it's, I've dealt
with that my whole life.
- [Interviewer] So where are
you living today, you're?
- In a shelter, The Navigation Center.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- It's run by former inmates,
so it's kind of weird.
You can definitely tell the
people it bothers and such.
- [Interviewer] And living
this, this unusual lifestyle,
living as a Carnie and now
as a trans gender woman
living on the street in San Francisco,
what, what experiences
have you had, good or bad?
- The people.
And you know, it seems like
the homeless seems to be,
part of it seems to be more the issue.
You know, I had no more choice of that.
Considering when I showed up
and what's going on right now,
then, I do anything, you
know, about my sexuality
or my fucking gender.
With that said, anyhow, it's just bigotry.
It's just taking another form.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, do you,
do you have romantic partners?
- I've had a couple since I've been here.
Not, not nearly enough.
- [Interviewer] Is that, is
that the stuff you do for money
or just you meet somebody
and you like them
and it goes to there.
- Yeah, I would do it for money,
if the opportunity came up.
- [Interviewer] You do
that as well sometimes?
- I would, yeah, absolutely, why not?
I enjoy it, and I just want to get work
at I something enjoy.
I know that sounds bad, doesn't it?
- [Interviewer] It depends
on how you look at it.
Where do you see your
life going from here?
- I don't know, I really don't.
- [Interviewer] But you're happy.
- Yeah, with the whole, things
that are going on right now,
it's, you know, don't
be stupid, but you know
you've kind of got to
live life for the moment.
I've always kind of been like that.
- [Interviewer] Lauren, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
good luck with wherever
you go from here, and I
hope your carnie season
gets back in gear.
- All right, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.